[Musique]
oui
trois morts des milliers de sinistrés le
cyclone syringa a dévasté l'île de la
réunion la région sud est la plus
touchée
la victoire de bernard tapie ne règle
rien à marseille
la droite a pris une claque mais la
gauche reste dans le brouillard
entracte dans la sphère téchiné
en attendant la cob dans ce journal un
dossier complet tout sur la sphère et
ses acteurs
la surprise est la honte à berlin ouest
les élections ont ramené une vague
d'extrême droite et de vieux fantômes
françois mitterrand par en 1 de demain
au même moment la fête religieuse dallas
la bad une des plus spectaculaires
reportage bonsoir il s'appelle firinga
un joli nom pour un méchant cyclone en
quelques heures il a dévasté l'île de la
réunion avec des vents de 220 km heure
il a provoqué des dégâts considérables
le bilan lui aussi est lourd il ya au
moins trois morts et plus de six mille
sinistrés images tropicale qui font
froid dans le dos dominique verdeilhan 6
heures à peine ont suffi pour que le
cyclone firinga offre aux réunionnais ce
spectacle de désolation immeubles
éventrés toitures arrachées arbres
couchés autos électriques déracinés
routes impraticables rendant les secours
difficiles
ce sont essentiellement le sud et l'est
de l'île qui ont été le plus durement
touché par des rafales de vent qui ont
atteint 250 km heure ce soir le bilan
est de trois morts un disparu
soixante blessés et plus de 6000 sans
abri un bilan provisoire
les autorités craignent de découvrir
d'autres victimes au fur et à mesure
qu'ils atteindront les villages pour
l'instant isolées à saint pierre la
situation est jugée critique l'hôpital a
été inondé les médecins opèrent les
pieds dans l'eau l'annnonce du cyclone
depuis sa formation le 25 janvier et son
passage à l'île maurice où il a fait un
mort et une dizaine de blessés a
néanmoins permis de mettre en alerte
tous les services de secours
ainsi on avait conseillé aux réunionnais
de rester chez eux ce week-end cet après
midi paris a dépêché de nombreux
renforts en hommes et en matériel
firinga qui a perdu de sa force c'est
diriger vers madagascar mais à réunion
il est synonyme d'apocalypse la
politique et si la victoire de bernard
tapie à marseille ne faisait plaisir à
personne
au lendemain de la victoire de l'homme
d'affaires dans la législative partielle
de la 6e circonscription des bouches du
rhône
au lendemain de cette victoire donc on
peut se poser la question à droite bien
sûr déception sur toute la ligne
à gauche la situation n'est pas
clarifiée loin de là al'approche des
municipales en quête de patrice volée
mais d'abord on écoute bernard tapie mon
seul souci
maintenant ça va être de faire en sorte
que pour que cette gauche gagne il y ait
une union bernard tapie hier soir un
oeil sur sa victoire un oeil sur les
municipales son élection il la gagnait
avec le soutien de toute la gauche
marseillaise michel pezet en tête mais à
une condition ne pas appuyer robert
vigouroux le maire sortant dans sa
campagne solitaire effectivement avoir
ce regard et permettre que peut-être sur
tel ou tel aspect de contradictions qui
semble aujourd'hui ses contradictions
disparaissent c'est un plus un plus
qu'ici on le croit ne sera sur aucune
liste mais voudrait bien cimenter la
gauche marseillaise hier soir petite
visite de remerciements à la mairie
pourtant le patron de l'om se maintient
à égale distance des deux candidats
socialistes et robert vigouroux lui joue
la montre je suis satisfait je le répète
de cette victoire les municipales je
n'ai pas commencé la campagne des listes
ne sont pas publiés ce sera fait en
temps voulu et pourtant la campagne
municipale est bel et bien lancée hier
la dynamique de la victoire a échappé à
jean claude gaudin
même si pour lui le succès de bernard
tapie n'est pas un événement politique
mais plutôt médiatique
je ne crois pas tu ne parles que ce
résultat soit bon marseille et d'autre
part je suis convaincu qu'il complique
la situation à gauche d'une manière
assez nette
unir la gauche marseillaise avec un ps
divisé et un pc contre tapis par
principe le pari sera plus que difficile
pour le nouveau locataire de l'assemblée
élections encore mais en allemagne cette
fois et les berlinois ont manifesté leur
révolte aujourd'hui s'ils ont protesté
dans la rue après le résultat de ces
élections
contre toute attente le parti d'extrême
droite dirigé par un ancien ss a obtenu
8 % des voix
gène fantômes du passé et interrogations
philippe rochot en allemagne les nazis 2
or interdisez les républicains plusieurs
milliers de manifestants ont crié leur
colère après la poussée de l'extrême
droite aux élections à la chambre des
députés de berlin ouest
on tablait sur une progression de 2% ils
augmentent leur score de 8 %
ils pourront ainsi envoyer deux députés
au parlement fédéral en 1990 il compte
près de 10 mille partisans en allemagne
fédérale leur chef c'est lui
franck youtuber 64 ans ancien ss son
slogan retour aux valeurs allemandes
dans sa campagne il a joué sur la peur
des berlinois peur des immigrés qui
représente ici 15% de la population
crise du logement
des problèmes qui n'ont guère été
évoquée par la majorité des chrétiens
démocrates de la cdu ou l'accord est
l'étoile à berlin ouest
étrangement ont montré que la cdoa
complètement négligé ces problèmes là
alors dans deux ans il y aura deux
députés d'extrême droite au bundestag le
parlement fédéral est ce que c'est
inquiétant ou est ce que c'est un
phénomène marginal
non c'est certainement en finale parce
que deux députés et des stray bottes à
beaune et akira comprends pas ce que 500
c'est certes un original mais la défaite
est cinglante pour le parti du
chancelier kohl qui perd 9% des
suffrages mais qui devra regagner la
confiance d'une bonne partie de la
droite ceux tentés par l'extrémisme
actualité internationale la mort d'un
prêtre polonais encore le père du
chocolate j'avais 31 ans il était très
proche de solidarité il aurait été
asphyxiées mais il n'est pas bien sûr
que cela soit un accident en roumanie
l'ambassadeur de grande bretagne a été
molesté à bucarest il voulait porter
lettre à l'opposante d'orner a donné à
cornet à pardon qui est vous le savez en
résidence surveillée l'ambassadeur a
reçu des coups des miliciens le foreign
office porte plainte
et puis au proche orient un nouvel
attentat à la voiture piégée à beyrouth
une voiture piégée au passage de georges
saadé le chef du parti des pâtes des
phalanges monsieur ça allait n'a pas été
touché mais l'explosion a fait cinq
morts et de nombreux blessés elle a eu
lieu dans le secteur chrétiens de
beyrouth
quand la vérité apparaît 25 ans après à
moscou des responsables américains
soviétiques et cubains se sont réunis
pour faire le point sur la fameuse crise
de cuba en 62 et pour éviter bien sûr
que de tels événements se reproduisent
une concertation qui a été l'occasion de
découvrir des faits importants que l'on
ignorait jusque là les découvertes qui
donne le frisson
michel mompontet 14 octobre 1962 deux
avions américains survolent cuba sur les
clichés photographiques pris par cette
patrouille les américains découvrent
vinci lot lance missiles installés en
grand secret par les soviétiques les
ogives nucléaires qui leur sont alors
destinée ne sont qu à des centaines de
kilomètres de là voguant vers la havane
sur des cargos russes
c'est tout du moins ce que croit kennedy
mais la réalité est tout autre
vingt têtes nucléaires soviétiques sont
déjà opérationnels à cuba deux cent
mille soldats y attendent une invasion
américaine washington ne l'a pourtant
jamais envisagée au comble du malentendu
dans cette crise des missiles castro
aurait semble-t-il même demandé à croûte
chauffe de lâcher une bombe atomique sur
new york en octobre 62
le leader cubain attendait une invasion
imaginaire
kennedy lui voulait empêcher
l'installation de missiles nucléaires
qui était déjà en place
un sommet d'incompréhension qui faillit
il ya 27 ans valoir qu'une troisième
guerre mondiale
enfin l'afghanistan c'est le grand
retrait de l'armée roger c'est la grande
peur dans kaboul que va-t-il se passer
après les diplomates eux aussi sont
partis les américains par exemple ont
amené aujourd'hui le drapeau à bannière
étoilée qui dominaient leur ambassade
les grands pays occidentaux font ou ont
fait de même
du côté français on sait que le chargé
d'affaires quittera la capitale afghane
demain en france
en attendant l'accord fait l'entracte
dans le grand cirque de la sphère
pechiney c'est en effet demain que la
commission des opérations de bourse va
remettre son rapport
aujourd'hui on a appris que la cob avait
demandé une aide judiciaire à la suisse
pour connaître notamment l'identité des
acquéreurs
c'est donc demain à la remise du rapport
que l'on saura s'il y a eu ou non de
véritables fraude en bout
au moment du rachat de la société
américaine american can par péchiney
c'est une affaire compliquée alors
antenne 2 a décidé de vous l'expliquer
clairement mais en détail
c'est le dossier de ce journal tout ce
que vous avez toujours voulu savoir sur
la sphère pechiney sans oser le demander
françoise joly christophe martet la
sphère pechiney infectant parfum de
scandale politico financier qui met en
scène des dizaines de protagonistes mais
trois hommes qui tiennent le haut de
l'affiché à la bibli le directeur de
cabinet de pierre bérégovoy une forte
personnalité qui lui vaut des inimitiés
montré du doigt il démissionne samir
traboulsi homme d'affaires libanais
l'homme des négociations délicates au
carnet d'adressés incontournable nelson
peltz financiers américains la réussite
très rapide trop pour certains qui
aimeraient le voir tomber
[Musique]
ces trois hommes on les retrouve le 12
juillet derrière ses fenêtres au
ministère des finances
cette rencontre marque le début des
négociations entre français et
américains pour la chatte d'american
cannes par péchiney tout au long de
l'été les rencontres se succèdent
ici en corse de yachts sont au
rendez-vous à bord samir traboulsi alain
boublil nelson peltz et des dirigeants
de paix chine
quelques jours plus tard monte-carlo
nouvelles discussions et puis c'est la
rupture à new york avant de se retrouver
à paris et de conclure finalement à palm
beach
la discrétion n'est plus de mise deux
jours avant l'annoncé officielle
un premier ministre rabhi lève un coin
du voile que j'attends pour l'animateur
en tout cas pourquoi populiste 6e ce
soit mais la france est on va vous
préparer c'est donc chose faite pour 6
milliards de francs pechiney s'offre le
numéro un mondial de l'emballage
american can
un bon coup industriels mais à new york
ce bon coup sans l'embout y les agents
de la sec le gendarme de wall street
soupçonne un délit d'initié
certains ont pu acheter 10 dollars d
actions qu'ils revendront 56 dollars une
fois le contrat signé pour la sec
cela n'a pu se faire qu'en bénéficiant
d'informations privilégiées
l'asec est convaincu de l'existence de
fuites
dès le début des négociations il y à des
initiés de la première heure dans le
collimateur se co finance une société
installée à genève dès le début des
pourparlers elle achète mais plus tard
lorsque rien ne va plus elle revend pour
acheter à nouveau quand l'accord est
trouvé
soko finances à 88 1000 titres en poche
sans profit 20 millions de francs
[Musique]
soko finances clame sa bonne foi elle
n'a fait qu'exécuter les ordres de cette
société idb niché dans les caraïbes
sur cette île dans gilad véritable
paradis fiscal difficile de savoir qui
se cache derrière idb des bureaux vides
à directeur absent
seuls sa femme est là ignorant qu'elle
est filmée dossier de l'été transmis à l
afrique avec le nom du client et à la
coop aussi depuis décembre les autorités
boursières françaises et américaines
connaissent donc l'identité du client 10
db est de souk aux finances de société
aux liens plus étroits qu'elle ne
l'annoncent derrière elle on retrouve
les mêmes noms des financier libanais
dont la route a souvent croisé celle de
samir traboulsi la filiale est balèze je
sais pas s'il existe si elle existe
la coop va le la trouver et de toute
façon en tout état de cause je n'en suis
pas responsable
comme je l'aï dit hier je ne suis pas
responsable de ce que font tous les
libanais partout dans le monde
loin de là
[Musique]
et la sek découvre d'autres achats
litigieux de dernière minute
deux cent vingt mille titres triangle
s'échange à wall street
trois jours avant l'annoncé officielle
du contrat
[Musique]
quatre acheteurs sont identifiés à paris
dont max théret vieux militant
socialiste reconverti dans les
placements financiers et roger patrice
pelât homme d'affaires proche de
françois mitterrand
[Musique]
c'est un homme patient je voulais
j'attends que je veux pas gêner
deschamps que la commission comprend les
raisons suivantes
ils ont besoin que leur tranquillité
pour bergerac pas qu'ils vous preniez le
rapport nous verrons en suisse et au
luxembourg l'asec trouve la crasse d'une
autre partie des actions litigieuses
mais là on ne sait toujours pas pour qui
ces actions ont été achetées
[Musique]
alors y at il eu délit d'initié réponse
oui pour les enquêteurs qui informés
qu'ils le directeur de cabinet alain
boublil qui dès le début et dans le
secret des négociations
l'intermédiaire
samir traboulsi nelson peltz le patron
d'american cannes ou peut-être jean
gandois le patron de pechiney voir l'un
de ses proches collaborateurs car
aujourd'hui jean gandois explique avoir
mis dans la confidence
une dizaine de personnes voilà donc ce
qu'on sait sur la sphère pechiney et
voilà les questions qui restent en
suspens alors fâché que demain donc je
voulais dit la cob remet son rapport et
demain aussi pierre bérégovoy le
ministre de l'économie des finances sera
l'invité de ce journal en direct pour
donner ses explications
alors demain ce style il s'assied on va
tout savoir ballons trop bas historique
à fignon ne sera pas tous pas tout de
suite loin de là ce rapport dont on
vient de parler va comprendre
l'environnement dizaine de pages cinq
noms déjà connus notamment ceux de
messieurs terré pelage au sua devraient
y figurer
d'autres nouveaux noms seront cités une
inconnue quel rôle ce rapport là qu'il
attribue à la boule il est à samir
traboulsi une certitude la justice va
être saisie il faudra donc compter sur
elle pour répondre à la véritable
question celle que pourrait ce reportage
qui a donné des informations aux initiés
mais en tout cas philippe demain ce sera
une étape et en particulier pour le
gouvernement
oui c'est une étape parce que en dehors
de la sphère pechiney il la sphère de la
société générale dont on parle également
beaucoup le gouvernement a deux sujets
importants de réflexion d'abord il
réfléchit aux moyens de modifier les
noyaux durs sans se casser les dents
comme sur la société générale c'est
l'objet du projet de loi qui sera
examiné demain en conseil des ministres
on va rechercher à la générale comme
ailleurs une sorte de paix négociée
permettant d'éviter une nouvelle guerre
de religion entre les champions du
nationalisation et ceux de la
privatisation ensuite le gouvernement
réfléchit aux moyens
aider les entreprises nationalisées à
trouver des capitaux et des partenaires
étrangers notamment
mais c'est un dossier assez explosif il
ne sera pas ouvert avant les municipales
et probablement pas avant le deuxième
semestre de l'année tout de même est ce
qu'on peut attendre assez vite des
changements d'hommes on a tout à l'est
les changements d'hommes seront très
importants et bon fournir les
indications sur les politiques qui vont
être menées en matière financière en
juillet il y aura des changements de
président dans les entreprises
nationalisées
ensuite des hommes comme jean
peyrelevade le président de l'uds ap le
premier assureur français qui
nationalise et ensuite claude bébéar un
autre assureur privé celui là devrait
jouer un rôle beaucoup plus important il
n'était pas très bien avec alain zouvi
ces deux hommes là un rôle beaucoup plus
important dans la transformation du
paysage financier enfin certains
responsables à la caisse des dépôts
notamment sont critiquées pour n'avoir
pas suffisamment averti pierre bérégovoy
des risques que comporte et cette
attaque contre la générale
donc en dehors de leur s aspect
spectaculaire et quasi policiers bien
ces affaires vont faire beaucoup bouger
les choses
merci philippe andré bergeron passe la
main après 25 ans à la tête de force
ouvrière demain en effet s'ouvre le
congrès de fo à vincennes ce sera le
dernier de monsieur bergeron
il n'y a pas de successeur désigné tout
va se passer pendant ces quelques jours
de congrès en fait il y a deux
prétendants véronique auger andré
bergeron et sans poulain en face le
concurrent les adversaires pousse la
guerre jusqu'à se refuser le pacte est
manifestement marc blondel 51 ans ne
déteste pas la bagarre
adepte de tauromachie il affirme avoir
déjà porté l'estocade
il faut que je vous explique
que généreux rien n'est joué pourtant
contre lui il ya son passé soutenu par
les trotskistes militants socialistes
francs maçons il fait peur à la base la
plus conservatrice
le tempérament je suis plutôt
contestataires moi je crois en la
primauté du social sur l'économie
j'ai essayé de ne pas faire le théorie
de préciser les choses
ça veut dire que mouvement syndical
développe des revendications
l'économie doit s'adapter pour les
satisfaire à son actif un sens aigu des
contacts une bonhomie à l'ats philippe
noiret et enfin selon sa fille elle-même
il possède une qualité très
caractéristique d'une lutte en force
ouvrière
sentiment de la défense de l'être humain
en tant que travailleur claude pitou 53
ans apparaît moins charismatique n'aime
pas se raconte se montrer il affirme
n'avoir aucune ambition personnelle
tout simplement ils auraient souhaité qu
andré bergeron manche en sa faveur
la tolérance est bien mais comme c'est
au rang d'une institution absolue ça
pose un peu problème dans un conte faut
savoir trancher le pitou série zone a
tourné pour la réforme pas pour la
révolution ils ne croient qu'en force
ouvrière c'est ça qui plaît bien
l'équilibré absolue entre spe la
philosophie la politique et syndicalisme
c'est ce que j'appelle moi l'équipe
absolue les kilos absolue que le trouve
mieux chez qui tous que chez nantes
blondel jusqu'à présent dre bergeron
avait toujours su préserver l'unité de
force ouvrière le syndicat
faute de dauphin désigné aura du mal à
rester solidaires au chapitre de la
justice deux hommes bien différent
maintenant un point comme important
entre la haine
il s'agit de deux criminels arrêtés dans
les alpes maritimes pour avoir commis
des attentats racistes sur la côte
d'azur notamment contre des foyers
sonacotra deux étrangers troubles
personnage
bruno gex racisme et anti communisme les
seuls mots d'ordre pour gilbert vachon
et nicolas gauche dont l'épopée
sanguinaire s'est arrêté hier à la
prison de nice gilbert vachon 67 ans
retraité niçois vite ici rue berlioz
c'est dans son appartement de
rez-de-jardin qu'il confectionnait ces
bombes que gouges à les poser cet ancien
68 eur passionnés d'explosifs menait une
vie apparemment tranquille avec sa femme
c'est en tout cas l'avis de ses voisins
c'était pas un grand bon gros parleur
contre sommes pas très bons pas prêt non
pas trop quoi en concert venant pas des
congés par un sympathisant du parti
nationaliste français et européens
groupuscules d'extrême-droite arv au
chant fréquentait aussi il ya quelques
années le fonds national
c'est un homme qui gravitaient dans les
milieux de droite et qui venaient
assister à nos réunions
manifestement il avait des propos disons
assez bizarroïdes
jusqu'au jour où dans une réunion
publique qu'il a tenus carrément des
propos antisémites
ce qui m'a valu de lui demander de
sortir
il a refusé de sortir je dois dire qu'il
ya eu un échange de coups
je crois même qu'elle ait porté plainte
barman au buffet de la gare de cannes
nicolas gauche 41 ans était l'homme de
main dervaux show bien connu des
services de police à eux deux ils
formaient un duo de choc à leur actif
l'explosion le 19 décembre dernier du
foyer d'immigrés de la sonacotra de
cagnes-sur-mer un mort dernier attentat
d'une série meurtrière qui avait
commencé en mai 85
je vous propose maintenant de voir
d'autres informations de l'actualité
française
en bref en images emmanuel vanier trois
enfants sont morts carbonisés dans
l'incendié de leur maison à carvin dans
le pas-de-calais selon les pompiers un
court circuit ou le mauvais
fonctionnement d'un poêle à charbon
serait à l'origine du drame
l' incendie s'est déclaré en pleine nuit
les parents ont réussi à sauver quatre
de leurs enfants mais les trois plus
jeunes âgés de 4 8 et 10 ans sont restés
prisonniers des flammes
carambolage en série sur les routes de
france 2 morts et 30 blessés dont
plusieurs sont grièvement atteints
le plus grave accident s'est produit
dans le finistère où quatre poids lourds
et une trentaine de voitures sont
entrées en collision
carambolage également dans le haut rhin
le val d'oise et le morbihan
partout les mêmes causes le verglas et
le brouillard la visibilité était
parfois inférieurs à 20 mètres qu'une
seule parade la prudence
[Musique]
le csa le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel a pris ses fonctions ce
matin neuf nouveaux sages dont la tâche
la plus urgente sera désigné un
président pour radio-france relents fort
l'actuel pdg ayant été lui-même nommé au
csa
autre dossier à l'étude la campagne des
municipales à la radio et à la
télévision et l'attribution des canaux
de diffusion sur le ca d'éviter des f1
françois mitterrand en inde il part
demain soir pour une visite officielle
trois étapes new delhi calcutta bombay
des liens forts existent déjà entre les
deux pays et 89 en inde
c'est l'année de la france au même
moment à allah la bad a lieu une grande
fête religieuse
un événement de l'hindouisme qui n'a
lieu qu'une fois par décade jacques
merlino bernard puisse au reportage ils
sont venus par tous les moyens et quel
que soit leur état physique
ils sont venus parfois de très loin en
quête d'éternité pour eux et pour leur
descendance jusqu'à la 70e génération
car c'est ainsi que l'ovale les textes
sacrés et sont venus participer aux
coûts mais là un événement cosmique qui
n'intervient que tous les 12 ans ils
sont déjà plus de dix millions dix
millions d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
réunis là où deux fleuves le gange et la
yamuna ne font plus qu'un avec une
rivière mythique à farah soit ce lieu
est l'un des sites les plus sacrés de la
religion hindoue c'est le lieu de toute
chose le commencement est
l'aboutissement avant la renaissance
c'est ici selon la bhagavad gita que
dieux et démons en se battant caceres la
coupe contenant la liqueur d'immortalité
c'est ici aussi qu'en février 1948
furent disperser les cendres du mahatma
gandhi
alors chaque matin après trois immersion
dans le gange
il s'assied face au soleil levant elise
la bhagavad gita cet homme est un ca 12
l'un de ces milliers d'indiens ayant
tout quitter et cherchant dans le
dénuement la voie du renoncement
mais le plus surprenant est que l'on
découvre ici les célèbres naga baba's
ces ermites qui d'habitude vivre à
l'écart loin du regard et qui ont une
farouche réputation ils sont considérés
comme des saints dans les autres indiens
car à tous ils ont véritablement
renoncer allant jusqu'à refuser de
porter des vêtements qui couvrent en
simplement leur peau de cendres qui leur
donne cette si étrange couleur
[Musique]
tout cela a une signification religieuse
nous venons d'endroits différents d'état
différent de tout pays
celui ci est tout jeune à peine 18 ans
et lui aussi nous explique qu'il a tout
abandonné famille étude maison pour
vivre comme les dieux ma vie est
consacrée à dieu ou cet autre encore qui
ne s'est jamais coupé les cheveux et qui
à 73 ans nous dit qu'il vit ainsi depuis
cinquante six années où ces mystiques
choisissent et définissent eux-mêmes les
voies d'accès à la scène crient certains
s'imposent détenant exercice de
mortification comme sonadac depuis huit
ans n'a jamais dormi couché ne s'est
confectionné ce support est sur un pied
dort debout le coup mais là a débuté le
14 janvier
il s'achèvera le 6 février ce jour là on
atteint ici 15 millions de personnes le
plus grand rassemblement religieux du
monde entier
sans transition beaucoup moins spirituel
le ski c'est le championnat du monde à
vail dans le colorado c'est parti depuis
hier soir antenne de vous le savez vous
fera vivre le plus possible toutes ces
épreuves il ya quelques minutes c'était
la première manche du slalom de
l'épreuve du combiné messieurs le point
tout de suite avec gérard holtz
paul-froment elle est au départ des tas
de tic mais surtout une tactique foncé
et cela va réussir paul-froment lte du
liechtenstein meilleur temps de la
première manche de ce slalom du combiné
son chrono 49 96 il devance au cab et le
véronais girardelli sur visionique 15e
franck piccard le champion olympique
français très très loin 26 viennent à
plus de trois secondes 71 pôles
fromelles deux circonstances a tellement
le slalom n'est pas sa spécialité il a
été opéré du genou il ya un mois et demi
mon but de reprendre confiance sur un
seul homme et d'avoir
malheureuse est très confiant pour la
suite des épreuves de ce plus qu'on
s'envoie confiant après une manche de
slalom
schmidt et 10e alphand est tombé tout
comme milliards le canadien la plus
belle chute de la matinée deuxième
manche à 20h30 le résultat en images sur
antenne 2 à 22 heures voilà gérard m'a
ôté ce que j'allais dire de la bouche
vers 22 heures un petit peu après la
marche du siècle deuxième manche de ce
combiné l'énigme du football français
cantona est il un cas désespéré
le marseillais s'était déjà fait exclure
de l'équipe de france pour avoir injurié
henri michel sélectionneur à l'époque
eh bien cette fois cantona est suspendu
jusqu'à nouvel ordre dans son club l'om
à cause d'une conduite inacceptable dans
un match amical
explications de jean ma mère a commencé
par la condamnation de michel hidalgo
lui la direction de l'olympique de
marseille a décidé conformément aux
dispositions du règlement intérieur du
club de suspendre eric cantona de
compétition professionnelle jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
cette décision est assortie de lourdes
sanctions financières toutes autres
manifestations de la part du joueur fera
l'objet d'une demande de résiliation de
contrat auprès des instances du football
sans commentaire tout comme les
supporters de sedan les dirigeants
marseillais n'ont pas apprécié le geste
de mauvaise humeur de leurs joueurs plus
professionnelle de cinéma que de
football dans une telle circonstance ces
quelques sifflets dans un match amical
justifié t-il autant de mépris quand on
a il est vrai est un habitué des gestes
déplacés
ces insultes à l'endroit d'henri michel
le sélectionneur en soir de championnat
l'ue avait déjà attiré les foudres
fédéral et une suspension d'un an de
toute rencontre international eric
cantona pourtant ne manquent pas de
talent mais sa gloire naissante risque
bien d'être
dans l'oeuf pour avoir oublié que
marquer des but nécessite des jambes
mais aussi de garder en toute
circonstance la tête haute et froides
voilà fin de ce journal dans quelques
instants laurent cabrol pour la météo
d'ailleurs il se contentera si j'ai bien
compris de recopier la météo d'hier vers
22h le ski donc gérable il a dit et puis
la dernière édition du journal ce sera
henri sannier vers 23h30 demain
télématin avec notamment la première
édition du journal de la rédaction c'est
marc hautement et catherine ceylac à
cette heure et puis l' invité des 4
vérités de gérard morin ce sera andré
bergeron tout cela dans télématin
présentée par roger zabel excellent de
soirée sur un thème de haguenau soir 20h
[Musique]